(suspenseful instrumental music)
(ground explosions)
- There is a war raging,
and the world is taking sides
but they don't want to get involved
with troops and guns.
So they're turning to a new weapon,
an invisible one,
a weapon that is only possible
because of our deeply
connected world economy.
- Sanctions.
(speaking foreign languages)
- Sanctions are this thing
that just get thrown around
like we should all just
understand what they mean
but sanctions are a kind of wonky,
bureaucratic tool for economic war,
and they're not super easy to understand
unless you crack them open,
and look at the mechanics
of how they work.
and that's what I want to do to today.
I wanna explain what
sanctions actually are
what their goal is,
and whether or not they actually work.
So let's go.
- The largest and most severe package.
- Of economic sanctions.
- That Russia has ever seen.
(speaking foreign language)
(ominous instrumental music)
- Before we dive into this video,
I quickly want to pause
for a commercial break,
and thank today's sponsor
who made this video possible.
Thank you BetterHelp for
sponsoring this video.
BetterHelp is a place
that is making therapy
more accessible to everyone
securely on the internet.
I'm a huge fan of therapy.
I've been doing therapy
for two and a half years,
and I really believe
in BetterHelp's mission
in making therapy more accessible.
Finding a therapist is not easy,
and often when you need therapy the most,
you're not in the best head space
to sit around and call a bunch of people,
and call your insurance and figure out
how to get a therapist.
With BetterHelp you take a quiz.
You get matched with someone
in their huge network
of licensed therapists,
and you can start communicating
with someone right away
within like 48 hours.
This is not a crisis line
or a self-help program.
This is like real legitimate
therapy done securely on the internet.
You can try this out for a discounted rate
at the link in my description
at BetterHelp.com/JohnnyHarris
where you'll get 10% off your first month.
You can try it out and see if
this is a good fit for you.
I love therapy.
It just changed my life.
Maybe it could do the same for you.
Thank you BetterHelp for
supporting my channel
and supporting this video.
Let's dive into sanctions.
(upbeat instrumental music)
In the most literal sense,
sanctions are this.
A piece of paper.
A bunch of lists that governments make.
That is what sanctions are.
Bureaucratic lists,
but this is a weapon of war.
It looks a little bit different
than the kinds of weapons
we're used to seeing in war,
but this is a weapon.
I am looking at a list
of hundreds and hundreds of names.
People's names and their addresses
as well as their aliases,
their birthdays, their tax ID numbers,
and anyone else that is also on the list
that they might be linked to.
Here in the US,
this list comes from an office
that is focused on thinking about
things that come in
and out of our country.
Sanctions are also this.
This comes from the white house,
and instead of people's names,
it has industries and
products like crude oil,
and liquified natural gas and coal,
and alcoholic beverages,
and diamonds and luxury goods.
And that is the point here.
What sanctions are, is
a giant list of people,
and things that are not allowed
to come into our country
or whatever country is
writing the sanction.
Oh, and the list includes,
the sale of US bank notes like cash.
Like you're not allowed to
send like a pallet of cash
to the Russian government,
according to Joe Biden.
Okay.
But here's where it gets interesting.
I want to tell you how all these boring
lists of paper
that were drafted up in the past few weeks
actually translate into economic war.
What is happening right now
in the global economy.
It's totally invisible.
It's not like tanks and guns.
You can't see it, but
it's having a huge effect.
And I wanna show you what that looks like.
(suspenseful instrumental music)
The best way to do this
is to look at Russia
before all of these sanctions.
You can see that Russia is connected
to the world in a lot of different ways.
I've color coded them for you.
Blue is everything that Russia exports
to other countries like oil, gold, coal.
Orange is everything
flowing the other way.
Stuff that Russia imports like iPhones
from the US or cars from Germany.
That's orange.
Green is all of the money
that needs to flow in and out of Russia
to keep things running.
That's money that businesses borrow
from foreign banks
or it's money that the Russian government
has put into US dollars or Euros
so that they have reserves
in case they need it.
We'll call this the financial stuff.
But then there's personal wealth,
which we'll put in purple.
One of the best parts
about being a Russian billionaire
is that you can spend
millions and millions
of dollars on a flat in London or Paris.
Or you can buy a yacht that you station
in the port in the South of France.
Russian billionaires have money and assets
all around the world
that they use as their global playground.
And then of course,
there's just regular Russians.
People who fly around the world
for tourism and business on airlines
that are from many different countries.
Those airlines fly over Russia
in Russian airspace
to get to a variety of destinations.
So yeah.
Russia is connected
like we all are to the global economy.
We trade, we move around
and everyone thrives.
It's great.
But then Russia invades
Ukraine a few weeks ago.
- We are coming on the air
because the war in Ukraine has begun.
(ominous instrumental music)
(ground explosion)
- "This is totally unacceptable."
Says the whole world.
We want to retaliate and show Putin
that we can't do that.
We have to set a precedent that you're not
allowed to invade your neighbor,
but we can't send troops
like we used to in the old days
because now we all have these big weapons
that could destroy our species.
So we can't like start fighting
with each other directly.
So what do we do?
"I know."
Says all the angry Western leaders.
"Let's start to mess with all of this.
That'll teach 'em."
Welcome to economic war,
which again like I said, starts like this.
A bunch of bureaucrats making lists
of people and things and vessels
that are now not allowed in their country.
But the hope is that it
creates a domino effect
that changes the course of this war.
And let me show you how that might look.
(suspenseful instrumental music)
Okay, so this is Russia
happily connected to the global economy.
These sanctions target
every one of these connections.
Like let's just look at imports.
One of the first things the EU did
was ban their countries
from selling luxury goods to Russia.
So the EU like, "Yeah.
Like we're pro Ukraine.
Like we're drafting up these sanctions
to hurt Russian billionaires."
And then out of nowhere,
Italy crops up and is like,
"Yeah, can we get an exemption?
Like, can we sell our goods?
Because we have like Gucci and Armani,
and come on."
And they actually got an exemption.
And then people were like, "Wait, no.
We're not giving you an exemption.
Just because you have all
these fancy designers.
Like come on Italy, get with it."
And Italy was like, "Ugh, fine."
But it wasn't just the EU who started
cutting off these connections.
Singapore banned their people
from selling electronics and computers,
and Taiwan where all
the microchips are made,
banned their companies
from selling those microchips to Russia,
which is a giant deal
because microchips are in everything.
(upbeat instrumental music)
Hundreds of international companies
that were in Russia
started to read the tea leaves,
and they're like, "We're out of here."
Like imagine if McDonald's and Ikea,
and Apple all left your city,
and then Netflix announced
that it no longer is streaming
in your country all in the same week.
Like this is real punishment.
This is what economic war looks like.
(upbeat instrumental music)
Okay, so that's imports.
The same thing starts
happening the other way.
Russia is a giant exporter of oil and gas,
and all sorts of fossil fuels.
And so the west trying to inflict
punishment on Russia.
Bans their countries from importing
Russian oil and gas.
That is a huge blow to Russia.
Like the second biggest exporter
of refined and unrefined
petroleum on earth.
The economic war is heating up,
and in the middle of all of this,
Vladimir Putin gets up and announces
that he sees this as an act of war,
and that he is putting his nuclear weapons
on high alert as a response.
(speaking in foreign language)
- Like this is
real war tactics we're talking about here
with real consequences.
All right.
Let's get to the fun sanctions
like watching rich people squirm.
(wine splurging)
- Oh.
- Back to this list
that the government made
of Russians who they really don't like.
(suspenseful instrumental music)
Those people now cannot
travel to our country,
and any country whose list they are on,
and any money that they
had in our country.
Like if they had it in an American bank,
it's now frozen.
They can't touch it.
Like it's totally inaccessible to them.
Their yachts and their private jets,
if they're in our
jurisdiction can be seized.
Everyone on this list is now a target,
and there are hundreds of them.
In fact, I've been deep in the OFAC
sanction list.
There are 712 Russians on this list
in case you wanted to know.
It's all there on the OFAC website.
So going through this list,
you kind of get curious.
You're like, "Who are these people?"
I now know their birthday
and their address,
and all of their aliases,
but like who are they?
Are these war criminals?
Are they like military
generals or something?
Well, no. There's actually
a few categories here.
The biggest one is
probably Russian lawmakers.
There are not 300 of them
that are now sanctioned
but then you have a bunch of rich Russians
who are the heads of defense, energy,
and media companies.
I see.
Make the most powerful
Russians uncomfortable,
and hopefully the will turn against Putin,
and get him to stop the war.
That's the logic.
And then you have this 26-year old
Instagram star
who's also on the sanctions list.
Wait what?
Yes.
Polina.
The daughter of the very rich
Foreign Minister of Russia
who lives a very fancy life in London.
And the UK sees this
and they're like, "No.
You've got blood on your hands too.
Put her on the list."
And she's on the list.
And now she can't travel to London
where she has a bunch of money,
and she has a big fancy flat,
and she's stuck in Russia.
She's on the list.
This is happening to hundreds
of rich Russian people.
And like we don't know
if all of them are
connected to Vladimir Putin.
We're just like,
"You're super rich and influential.
So we're gonna make your life hard."
Please change this.
Speaking of travel,
tons of countries have written sanctions
that ban Russian airlines
from entering their airspace,
and tons of airlines
have cut their routes to Russia.
So now the flow of people,
just human beings, tourists,
and business travelers
has come to a screeching halt.
Okay.
Finally, the last category is big money.
This is actually like
the hardest one to see,
and understand,
but maybe the biggest and most important.
You have to understand
that the Russian government
holds on to tons of
reserves in other currencies
like Dollars and Euros and British Pounds.
They do this because if their currency,
the Rubles, falls,
they can take their
Dollars and buy a bunch
of Rubles and raise the price back up,
and stabilize it.
But now all of their foreign reserves,
their Euros and Dollars are frozen
in like American and like British banks.
♪ You wanna build a snowman ♪
The Russian government
can't get their hands
on their money in other countries.
Okay, but the finance thing gets crazier.
Russian banks were then kicked out
of the system where banks can send
giant amounts of money to each other.
It's called SWIFT.
They were kicked out.
Now, they have to route
all their big payments
through like China,
which is like their one
friend in all of this.
And one more on the finance piece,
regular Russians can't use
their credit cards anymore
or their debit cards
because Visa, MasterCard,
American Express all pulled out of Russia.
Like that would suck.
So all of this is to say,
that Russia went from looking like this
to looking like this.
Totally isolated.
And that was the goal.
To isolate Russia from the global economy,
and make them feel pressure on all levels.
The people, the oligarchs,
the government, the military,
the hope here is that the rich
Russian billionaires
who have a lot of influence in politics
as well as the people
who are now suffering
because they can't get
in on the global economy,
they will all look to
Putin and be like, "Dude.
Enough, we're done."
So the question is, will it work?
Well, it depends on what your definition
of work is.
In terms of creating economic pain.
Yes, it's already working.
I mean look at how hard the Ruble crashed
after the war started.
Because remember,
the government can't get
its hands on all of its
foreign reserves to help stabilize
their currency.
The Moscow Stock Exchange
closed down for weeks.
The economy is shrinking.
There is scarcity in Russia.
But for me,
the definition of will this work,
is will this change Vladimir Putin's mind
to get him to stop
fighting this stupid war?
And that's a question I do not know
the answer to
because sanctions are
not like normal weapons.
We've had guns and missiles and bombs
for a long time.
We know how they work.
We know how they deter people.
We know who they hurt
but sanctions are not that old,
they're as old as our fairly new
Global Economic Order.
We make these lists and put on these bans
for travel and industries
and financial systems.
And we just sort of hope
that the ripple effect
makes it to Vladimir Putin's brain.
But I'm just not sure
Putin is a rational actor anymore.
And that is the
contradiction of sanctions.
Is usually we put sanctions
on countries like North Korea.
These pariah states where the leader
is not a rational actor anymore.
They're bent on some
weird ideological vision.
They're surrounded by a bunch of yes men.
And so sanctions turn into just another
narrative that they can use to say,
"We are the victims.
We are embattled."
The rest of the world is at war with us.
Plus frankly, Russia still has a way out
of some of these sanctions.
China is still their ally in this,
and China is deeply connected
to the world economy.
Oh and also, do we really think
that Russian billionaires
are gonna be stopped
by a list from a bunch of bureaucrats?
These people are well-resourced.
They're gonna find ways
to get around the sanctions
whether it's shell companies
or middleman or whatever.
It's just gonna be a
little less convenient
for them.
So in the end,
it's the Russian people
who are gonna suffer
the most here.
Well, that is after the real victims
of this whole thing, the Ukrainian people
who have had country
senselessly stolen from them.
(soft instrumental music)